c'est un honneur pour moi de m'adresser au congrès
des mondes qui rassemblent désormais toujours de nombreux
les principaux dirigeants français
société, je sais que ces Nadra m'ont entendu
et membres du Parlement français du Ministre
du gouvernement des préfets, des chefs de villes et
élus municipaux président de la République française
la république tu représentes des millions
citoyens de France, je veux vous expliquer
aujourd'hui, ce qui est le plus important maintenant pour
des millions d'Ukrainiens que je dirige autant que possible
plus précisément, la guerre russe a frappé
tout le territoire de l'Ukraine mais les occupants
temporairement réussi à capturer une partie
quel est le territoire de dix de nos régions
10 oblasts d'Ukraine comptent plus de 11 000 habitants
colonies de ces 11 mille seulement
imaginez le nombre total de villes et de villages
de l'Ukraine tombée sous occupation
plus de trois mille sept cents sont grands
villes et petites villes
aujourd'hui, il n'y a que des colonies et des villages forts
à quelques maisons de là, c'est une vie très différente
c'était mais maintenant nous voyons dans tout cela
dans les zones peuplées, on est complètement absent
toutes les possibilités sont normales et gratuites
vivre, nous avons réussi à nous libérer de
L'occupation russe compte déjà plus d'un millier
800 règlements et conséquences
les métiers sont très similaires partout
Les soldats russes ont réussi à poser des mines
ils ont remplacé tout ce que les occupants géraient
ils ont volé un total de
Des centaines de milliers de maisons ont été détruites en Ukraine
et des dégâts
des milliers d'objets sociaux sont des occupants
laisser derrière lui complètement détruit
imaginez l'infrastructure telle qu'elle est composée de personnes
occupation vécue pendant six mois sans communication
L'approvisionnement en électricité et en eau est normal
Je vais donner un exemple d'une ville, Kherson
une ville du sud de l'Ukraine, le centre régional
le port de Kherson, ainsi que toute la région, sont devenus nouveaux
un foyer pour de nombreux habitants de Crimée
a quitté la péninsule après lui
capture par la Russie en 2014
l'armée russe a occupé Kherson au printemps
cette année, ils ont commencé le 11 novembre
libération de la ville, qu'y verra-t-on
sur 300 000 citoyens qui vivaient à Kherson
avant
laissé en ville pour être près d'eux
il n'y avait rien, il n'y avait pas d'électricité
bien sûr, il n'y avait pas d'eau avant la nôtre
au retour, une pharmacie ouverte dans la ville
nous reprenons le travail du domaine médical
fourniture de services sociaux aux Russes
l'armée n'a pas seulement volé les gens
en retirant tout ce qui a de la valeur qu'ils ont cassé ou
détruit tout l'équipement qui pourrait
travailler à rétablir la connexion entre les gens et
ils fournissent, par exemple, de la chaleur en hiver
bâtiments administratifs minés et
certains d'entre eux doivent juste être explosés
parce qu'il est impossible de les déminer sans prendre des risques
Kherson a toujours été paisible et
une ville calme du Sud Maintenant à nous
il faudra des années pour guérir
ses blessures après l'occupation russe d'A
en général, les villes et villages qui nous appartiennent encore
libérer et restaurer environ deux autres
des milliers, au moins des dizaines d'entre eux ont été détruits
par les coups de l'armée russe complètement comme
Marioupol ou Volnovakha sont de chers amis de Kolya
L'Ukraine demande de l'aide dans ce domaine
la guerre n'est pas seulement une question d'affrontement
les États ne parlent pas seulement de ce qu'est la Russie
est venu pour notre terre et nos ressources
vouloir s'approprier ce choc des deux
attitudes opposées envers les gens et envers la vie
Quand la Russie arrive en ville, elle n'y est pas
il ne reste plus rien du tout
la vie normale que la Russie apporte
Nous ne réprimons pas, n'abusons pas, n'enlevons pas les gens
juste la propriété, il y a des milliers d'exemples en particulier
que l'armée russe simplement
des immeubles résidentiels ou des voitures ont été abattus
sur la route il y a des milliers de preuves que
extraction et destruction de l'énergie
formation médicale et autres
les infrastructures en Ukraine sont conscientes
Ils recherchent la politique russe
Les Ukrainiens ne pourraient tout simplement pas vivre de cette situation
atterrit lorsque le drapeau ukrainien
retourne sur le territoire libéré
nous faisons tout pour revenir avec lui
normale
une telle vie à laquelle tu es habitué dans la tienne
villes C'est pourquoi l'Ukraine est si reconnaissante envers tout le monde
qui nous soutiendra dans nos finances de défense
la reconstruction est littéralement une aide
sauver des vies Maintenant, avant l'hiver
fait face à l'une des plus grandes menaces
pendant une guerre russe à grande échelle
la terreur des missiles a détruit près de la moitié
de notre infrastructure énergétique et nous
nous savons que la crème a mis la tâche plus loin
frapper des objets énergétiques pour les transformer
le froid de l'hiver sur les armes de destruction massive
La Russie veut le faire depuis l’ensemble du territoire
L'Ukraine est ce qu'elle fait aux pays occupés
veut détruire la vie dans les villes et les villages
Bien sûr
Bien sûr, nous nous y opposons littéralement
J'ai parlé avec M. le Président hier
avec un macron manuel sur ce qu'on peut faire
faisons ensemble pour nous protéger contre cela
nous avons des tactiques russes claires
accords, en particulier celui sur
début décembre pour tenir une conférence sur
la reconstruction rapide de l'Ukraine est déjà possible
Selon le plan, notre plan est rapide
restauration de l'Ukraine et j'invite tout le monde
vous de rejoindre la conférence et
des efforts appropriés, je vous invite aussi
contacter l'ambassade d'Ukraine à
France pour savoir quelles sont les autres lignes disponibles
l'aide existe pour passer cet hiver et non
laissons la Russie transformer le froid en un outil
nous avons besoin de terreur et d'assujettissement
beaucoup de choses provenant de différents générateurs
Allumez Starlink. Pour nous, ce n'est pas
juste une question sur l'équipement pour l'Ukraine
il
ainsi qu'une aide à l'échange ou
équipement pour pompiers et sauveteurs
pour nos médecins, ce qui est déjà prévu sur
niveaux des villes et communes françaises
fourniture de groupes électrogènes et de systèmes spécifiques
la communication est une protection absolument claire des personnes
Je vous encourage également à être très
béton béton dans l'aide et
soutenir la protection contre le terrorisme de nos villes
communautés ensemble, nous pourrons certainement le faire, merci
pour votre attention et merci pour votre soutien.
Ukraine
[musique]